dea
2012年ゴールデンウィーク館南にてソウルに来ていつかみホテルで出会ったジョン
というごっついノルウェー人と間何も散策中出発して3時間が経った頃あらへんなり僕
がジョンに聞くああなんか食べをは即なんかどう
和食がなんだかよくわからんけど彼にと生きているもの以外なら大丈夫な問題ない
1個10分後
あぴこと黒い文字で書かれたレッスンを発見して中に挙げる
英語であいさつしてみるといきなり no と言われたので日本語できますカットキー
と魅力するとな
ジャパンバー落ち着いてミスターキーのと思いながらソ歳といって2名という香りに
ピースをするテーブルにつくチャングンソクにそっとにな女が現れ水とも脱ぎ茶とも
つかないのみ
のとメニューを渡してきた各ページの最新竹膳菜定食2死というふうに感じが書かれて
いるそれ以外は全部ハングルタフトメニューから目を上げるとジョンの命が泳いでいる
どうするここ大丈夫絶対大丈夫ちゃんとした和食レストランなら何を頼んでもハズレは
ないからそういった僕は超業と運足調子および
定食のところ
によっている japanese で言えば1000円のものを適当に指さすそして2
とゆっくりながらまたピースをするグンソクはデート行って厨房に消えた
10分後
生きたままの彼にしか乗っていない皿が運ばれてきた
eaa
me